I was coming here I was thinking about
this conference and the burden of
history as it were and it suddenly is a
remarkable situation with the simple it
reminded me because I recently read a
very interesting book it reminded me of
what the count Stanislav karnovsky said
in 1866 the you know the complexity of
the problem from the a 17-16 what heaven
ascension into the present and I knowing
what other people thought this is what
he said this is awkward kind of the
translation we could be some time for
making nice what isn't what he said and
I quote the Ruthenian nationality should
not be destroyed in Alicia it should be
cultivated then it will be a reinforced
unbeatable it will remain loose but it
will remain in the who's happy feel
domingos but it will be united in a
brotherly fashion with Poland then in it
to a common objective I mean when you
think about the historical process that
in here today let's say how close he is
to the new situation that exists in the
world he thought was the only one who
thought that when he needed 66 some
they know well anyway that was another
remarkable idea for somebody for account
and white so it was slightly to the
right of center as I guess it comes with
me well he done this one just ponder
upon the problems that side is going to
histories and what happened at they
change well you have heard one session
already this session will deal with the
20th century that's a session that is
much more complex in some ways than the
previous centuries and to discuss the
problems of the top 10 42 and it's
aftermath we have two outstanding
specialists in the field when his
professor unfaded no bar from the
Jagiellonian University who specializes
in East European history of the 20th
century and it's also member for the
polish academy of sciences in carpet and
our second speaker is historian from the
Institute of historical studies also
specializing in 20th century wrote a lot
of articles but
what interested me both because I spent
some time on the problem of illusion
that we published three of sending
bodies on central now so without any
further cool may I invite professor am j
Noah from the Union University that's
where my professor ping from Oscar
Whisky without him I would be a lawyer
but he was such a magnificent professor
that I could have missed up or put it in
his lawyer myself and that's it more
please thank you thank you very much for
the invitation for this outstanding
conference and for this introduction and
as I understand my duty here is to
present current polish historiography of
the subject namely of Polish Ukrainian
relations between the beginning of World
War one and the beginning of World War
two without the world war two itself
which will be the subject of the
subsequent discussion if we want to have
a general look on the contemporary
polish historiography of Ukrainian
policy period relations we find a really
a new a pumpkin use this word historical
narrative of this
of this particular subject it was formed
mostly by new political situation after
1989 that was influenced by two
different